this is kind of the way it is in the the
maths syllabus the continuum limit you
go through from life you know
kindiy all the way up until like now at
the beginning and at the early stages
all the way through you kind of learn
about things and you don't know why they
are there just kind of it's kind of like
the opening scene of a movie before like
you know the title credits run and a
company like what's going on and it's
something some character appears and I
do something miss to she don't
understand you're like what is the point
of this and if it's a good director
because sometimes there's no explanation
at the end like the lost TV series they
were just making it's a good director
everything gonna be it's like AHA there
will be like a payoff at the end you
know like um like sleep okay so Snape is
the perfect kind of character you like
why are you doing that what a jerk and
then of you like oh oh the feels okay so
this kind of thing is thinking something
that you learn in you seven it's finally
explained you finally okay so we look at
two formulas involving volume okay now
the first one is the volume on this
shape and I actually would like you to
draw it quickly cool because we're gonna
use this as sort of some basic quirky
before we get to our continued plate
this of course is our current right so
to work out the volume of a cone just
like a volume of a cylinder you need two
dimensions my two teachers do you need
okay good so you need a perpendicular
height election and you need the radius
of the base so you need this distance in
here okay once you have these two you
get a formula which is it's very closely
related to modular so does everybody
very good sir interestingly this always
puzzled me the volume of a cone is
exactly 1/3 the volume of this cylinder
with the same dimensions the same code
base and the same fine okay now the
question is how do we come about with
this result and how to use integration
to help us solve this is a particular
kind of shape right it's a volume that
can be formed as a solid of revolution
right a solid of revolution how in what
axis is a retainer what has rotated
around all right
well in this one the way I'd put I've
drawn up right okay
and I've rotated around this vertical
axis right I've done it that way so I'm
going to be taking an area like this
okay and I'm going to be rotating around
the y-axis okay so in order to translate
that over to this okay
this is a bit tricky I want to make this
as easy as I possibly can okay so in
order to do that I'm actually going to
number one turn this on its side and
number two rather than have it start
sort of at the bottom here we're going
to have to start at the top you'll see
why in a second okay so all I need is
this triangular shape show you the shape
so it's a straight line that's gonna be
the function that leads me it's in this
code once I do the rotation okay
so I'm actually going to draw the line
something like this okay here's a
straight line and I'm doing the code
kind of sitting on its side right so see
this blue triangle that I shaded in
that's the area that's being rotated
that forms the volume so that sideways
blue triangle I'm going to put here okay
so now you can see I'm rotating around
the x-axis okay now by the way the
reason why I'm choosing to rotate around
the x-axis rather than the y-axis is
because we tend to get functions Y as a
function of X X tends to be the
independent variable and Y tends to be
the dependent one right so therefore
I'll give you generally is easier to
integrate with respect to X okay in this
case as you'll see we could turn around
easily but I'm going to stay with this
way because it's more straightforward so
when I were taking around this way again
if you've got your ruler there right
measure up to however high that ordinate
went and then measure the same distance
down to the bottom here so you're
getting something that should be roughly
symmetrical right looks to me on line
something like that and then we're going
to draw the circular base over here
there you go so you can see when look at
this cone on its side
and that completes our solid okay so you
can see how this equates to this yes
okay good now we've got some boundaries
right I've got zero over there and then
I've got this boundary here now hold on
a second I'm looking at the code on sign
it okay so how long do I want this
length to be according to what I've got
I want that to the height right
this is horizontal but it corresponds to
the planet so therefore that coordinate
that x-coordinate should be H right that
would make it eight units PI and the
same way I want this radius to be ah
okay now that's the last piece of
information I need to actually get the
equation of this line okay it's a
straight line and it passes through the
origin so that means it's in the form y
equals MX where m is the gradient of the
one what is the gradient of this line
okay Brendan yeah very good it's great
it is rise over run yeah and I have the
whole rise of you the whole run there
are on H okay that's rise over run so
there is my gradient which gives me the
equation of a straight line that's all
the pieces I need just watch this okay
no volume it equals to what are my
boundaries lower and I thought yeah very
good
North H unless you now the things that
we're adding up together the series of
things behind over our syllabus okay so
this part here is going to be PI R
squared H but be careful the radii of
correspond to this guy here right it's
like has change
way through if I had a look at each
different slice they've each got a
different height which means a different
range so I've got PI times y squared
right which is R on H x squared
there's my y squared with respect to X
and there's those infinitesimally thin
width that I was dealing with before
okay that was the hardest part of this
right do you see that this is my PI R
squared H okay but this corresponds to
my vertical height and it's changing its
a function okay so that's why I just put
our there okay now just before I go and
actually carry out the integration you
can see how the whole bunch of clothes
that's in there right so I don't need to
worry about them as I go through the
process of integration the easy constant
of course to identifies the PI that can
take out the front
what other Kosan do I end up with yeah
very good
this whole thing gets squared token R
squared divided by an H squared so I'm
going to slap that at the front okay so
that's Mike what's the coefficient
taking it out of the integrand which
leaves me with this super super easy to
do it with right so let's go ahead let's
integrate their primitive function of
course is extras on three right how it
goes up and you divide by the power and
now we're about to evaluate at our upper
and lower bounds yeah so PI R squared on
H squared still hanging out the front
there what happens when you evaluate at
the upper boundary yeah we're good h
cubed 1 3 u evaluated at the low battery
just gives you take away zero okay so
that's something I don't need to worry
about now and then when you have a
little key like boom I have some anxious
that are gonna cancel right I've got to
agency over three of them then these are
all going leaving one behind okay which
leaves you with magically a PI R squared
pitch is that beautiful or is that
beautiful right it's really simple maths
once you know where this comes from
immediately if you met this in your 7
you'd be like is there a curly
okay it had to wait for now how much
Matt's like we had to develop
differentiation then integration and
then in this particular version its
application of integration to get to
this result that you have known from
very many years okay